[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to our podcast
and the series called High School
memories my name is okar Fates and I
will be your host today so without
further Ado let's dive into today's
episode and embark on the great journey
together get ready to be engaged and
entertained and inspired today's topic
will be about sports Central where
patient meets play our first segment is
headlines and hot takes let's check
things off with the latest headlines and
some hot takes we are covering the most
Buzz Worth news in Sports World from the
NBA to the NFL soccer and everything in
between and of course we will provide
our own opinions and analyzes
what's your hot take for today well I've
got a bold prediction for this week's
big game you will have to stay tuned to
find out what is it now we are at second
segment that is called player profile in
this segment we are featuring an
exclusive interview with a remakable
athlete we will delve into their career
personal journey and their impact
they've made both on the field Our Guest
today is Michael Jordan a basketball
star he wrote history at basketball he's
on top at the basketball everyone knows
him he won six championships with the
bulls and he named finals and MVP all
six times he was NBA's most valuable
player five times and a 14 time as
Allstar he was allstar game 14 times and
defensive player of the Earth
he was all defensive first team nine
times and the NBA scoring leader 10
times Jordan's impact on the game can be
seen in in a number of ways firstly he
popular
popularized the game of the basketball
making it one of the most popular sports
in the world he was a global icon now we
are at the third segment called fans
corners Sports Central wouldn't be
complete without hearing from our
amazing listeners it's time for fans
Corner we we've received some fantastic
questions and comments and we are going
to tackle a few of them that's right our
listeners are the heart and soul of this
podcast we came to the fourth segment
game breakdown now let's get into some
game analyz
we will be breaking down the best game
of all time that was at 1997 Chicago
Bulls and with uan Jaz of course Michael
Jordan was the MVP at that game the game
was on June 13 the game ended 8 to6 with
94 Chicago Bulls at the game the first
round just scored 23 Bulls scored 17
then the second round ja scored again
more more that again more they scored 21
but Bulls scored 20 then the third round
again just won the round for one point
oh no sorry in the third
round was won by the Bulls for one
points not
ja Bulls scored 27 ja scored 26 but ja
was still winning then the last round
Bulls scored 26 but just only only could
score 16 the game ended 86 with 90 as I
said for Chicago Bulls now we came to
our segment number five that is called
upcoming events looking ahead we will
give you a sneak peek at the exciting
sports
events up in the next week whether it's
the playoffs a championship match or a
mayor tournament we got you covered and
don't forget we will share our predict
predictions and what to watch for the
for in each of these events now we came
to our last segment that is the sixth
segment in the in this segment we will
talk about history this segment is
called history of basketball the sport
that is very popular in our daily life
basketball first began in N
1891 it was invented by James
nouth as being a less injury prone sport
than football he was 30 he was 31y old
graduated student when he created the
sport keeping players indoors during the
winter the game be became instabil quite
quickly and it grew very popular popular
into the 7th 7th Century now let's come
into the three facts about the history
of basketball oh there's a fun fact the
first Hoops were actually just Peach
baskets and the first backround
backboards were made wire like imagine
you throw the rubbish to the rubbish
Bean like they created the game like
that the game became an official Olympic
event at the summer games in Berlin
Germany in
1936 the original 11 teams of basketball
were the Boston Celtics providance steam
rollers New York cakers
bers
Philadelphia Warriors Pittsburg Iron Man
and Washington Capitals were the East
Division and clev
Rebels Detroit Falcons Toronto house
qu Chicago STS and St lest bombers were
the west
division you can see that the you can
see that the names Chang a lot from that
time so thank you so much for joining us
this episode of high school memories
it's been an incredible
journey and we we are so glad you came
along for the right until next time take
[Music]
care